the presidential election is just 99
days away and a new cbs news
battleground tracker poll shows
former vice president joe biden leading
president trump
by 10 points nationally but 13 percent
of non-trump voters say they could still
change their mind by election day and
vote for the president
joining us now are cbs news political
contributors robbie mook hillary
clinton's
2016 campaign manager and terry sullivan
who managed marco rubio's 2016 campaign
good morning gentlemen great to see you
again it's been a while
as robbie let me start with you because
i biden
leads significantly in most national
polls but the margins really matter here
and especially in the battleground
states and explain why robbie
yeah well obviously the electoral
college chooses the president
not the popular vote and so just looking
at
honestly the popular vote number doesn't
really matter at all um
but in those battleground states and a
lot of the polls that i've been seeing
and i think your polls reflected this as
well you know we're seeing that biden's
maybe at 50
51 which is really good however
there still is room for trump to catch
up there's you know room for him to get
to say 50 50 or
49 51 that's getting right in that
margin of error
so i would not be sitting comfortably if
i were the biden folks right now
and i think activists around the country
should still you know pedal to the metal
uh all in on this because uh you know i
think i think
we're a long way out and the dynamic
here could totally change
yeah terry as we mentioned 13 percent of
non-front voters say they could
uh change their minds still vote for the
president if
if you are the president what's the
demographic you are most concerned about
here
you know it's it's senior voters uh he
uh outperformed with
55 plus voters uh four years ago
and he needs to do that again and that's
critical for him and you look at a state
like florida
where his real clear politics average
polling is about
seven points behind biden that is a huge
problem for him
he's got to make that up with senior
voters if he doesn't win florida this
thing's over form and and that is
critical they've got to focus on seniors
and especially on seniors in florida
robbie the president's handling of the
pandemic has been a has been a big issue
cost him a lot of points in the polls
he's he's shifted his his strategy a bit
in the last week or so can he turn this
around
in the view of voters do you think
yeah i mean like i said it is still
early as much as it may not feel that
way it is still early
everything could change however i think
the president is doing
essentially everything he can do right
now uh to help joe biden win
um and he he's he kind of brought back
out his 2016
campaign playbook which was the bombast
and
uh uh you know all kinds of assertions
that weren't true
um he's in charge now you know he's
accountable he
is uh the way things are and
he needs to show uh maturity about how
he's managing the situation he needs to
show results
and what's been just mind-boggling to me
is he continues to
choose these fights that prove uh
not just that he's in a pretty extreme
and hateful place frankly
uh uh you know in terms of uh trying to
bring this country together
um but he's totally ignoring the issue
that everybody cares about which is this
pandemic
um and to your point he's tried a few
things here or there but
uh you know telling us to wear masks but
for example he's also sending
uh federal officials uh and and stoking
um uh division in in american cities and
so
um i think it's going to be very hard
for him
unless uh he gets his act together but
there is still time and that's why i've
been
saying to democrats you know we can't
let up here there's still room for this
race
to tighten up terry the president has
continued to criticize the process of
mail-in voting say that it could rig
the election could that strategy that
he's using in reference to that
actually backfire on him and if so why
yeah
absolutely back to florida again i mean
look
republicans do an amazing job every
election cycle especially in
presidential
election cycles on the absentee
balloting
in early voting in florida they
outperformed democrats consistently here
so doing anything to suppress that
only hurts republicans in a key state
like florida
and so i you know that is a real problem
for him but one thing i will say is i
disagree with robbie
look the only path that that donald
trump has
forward to to win uh and it's a real
path but is to make this race about joe
biden
as long as this race is about the
pandemic or about
donald trump he can't control the
pandemic uh
and and more importantly he absolutely
uh can't control donald trump so what he
can do
is drive his message on joe biden
and make this a referendum on joe biden
not on donald trump
and his presidency robbie how
significant is joe biden's vp
pick and who would you choose
well i definitely think it's a bit more
important than it's been in the past
because i think people do see this as a
passing of the torch in a way for the
party
um and in a race where biden's not able
to go out and campaign much this is a
very significant event
um that said i do think it's important
for us always to keep in mind people
vote for the top of the ticket
uh not the number two look i i love the
options
uh that that i'm hearing you know
everybody from someone like susan rice
who has tremendous
uh foreign policy experience to karen
bass who you know i've worked with in
the house of representatives kamala
harris also from california those are
just some of the names
i think any of these folks are are going
to be great
but again i we shouldn't see that
somehow as a replacement for biden this
is his campaign his message
uh you know he's gonna need to go earn
it okay you love him also but who would
you pick robbie
[Laughter]
well i think susan rice is really
interesting i think she has that foreign
policy experience
i think biden spent a lot of time with
her in that place
i i believe there's a lot of trust
between those two so
i think that's a great choice but you
know when i was talking to hillary about
this back in 16 what matters at the end
of the day is that trust between these
two people
he needs to believe that she's ready to
be president of the united states so
that's what really matters here
all right robbie mcterry sullivan thank
you both great to see you